Kumail Nanjiani not able yeah tonight
through apparently no fault of his own
Kumail Nanjiani
[Applause]
she was like a recovering stroke vixen
ja that's it that's a trademarked
Richter's zinger and krypter yeah so our
only guest tonight has been my assistant
for almost 10 years
some of you know her she's been my loyal
assistant we've been through a lot
together and she always tells it like it
is please welcome ladies and gentlemen
Miz Sona more obsessive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now Sona we told you how long ago we
didn't explain I think Jeff Ross our
producer just said get into makeup yes
you didn't know why no one told me
anything but kind of like how my job is
just regularly no one tells you anything
and so you do as you're told so we told
you to get into makeup and then you did
and then at what point did you realize
you were going to be the guest on the
show tonight and not Kumail Nanjiani I
think right when I was walking in like
when you called my name I was like oh
[ __ ] they really ran out of stuff to do
yeah
come in just relax you look fantastic
what are you doing crunchy okay no no
it's it's fine
it's cool let's tell people a little bit
about you you've been working with me
for almost a decade for over a decade I
said working
[Laughter]
she goofs off a lot actually not kidding
now we have a lot of misadventures
together yeah well how would you say it
is working for me and you can be honest
just it's we have a fun chemistry don't
look at me is it would you say fun yeah
would you say dysfunctional
dysfunctional we have a highly
dysfunctional relation highly dispersed
fun in there there's fun there's fun in
dysfunction that's why I see what you're
doing yeah but working for you first of
all I mean I've been working for for
over 10 years so obviously I like it
yeah but there are times when I want to
like poison your food
I really think about ways to kill you
yeah loli yeah I'm kind of a crazy
person I think we can say what are you
doing characters for all the Sun yeah
let's let's take it easy on those you
are you have a dog yeah I have a dog oke
Oke yeah and we've talked about this you
sent me this text and Annie this is a
true story she sent me this text that
Biscay said my dog is sick and I'm gonna
be late and so I'm not gonna I'll just
get in when I can but I that's not what
she said the exact text I'll tell it to
you right now and I read it really
quickly and the dog's name is okey and
so the text said okay what is it well
her name is spelled okay I yeah okay I
oh yeah when you read okay so I just
read okay I'm [ __ ] everywhere and
can't stop but I'll be in soon I was
like I don't want if they you have that
issue first of all I didn't understand
that you were going to the bathroom
everywhere and then you said I'll be in
real soon I'm like no I don't want yeah
and I was like what do you mean white my
dog sick like dumb thing yeah we need to
get a sitcom let's get to the crux of
the issue the crux of the issue is it's
something that that's for real guests
yes you can have some water
ah the audience turned on me immediately
you're enjoying it too much so you're
looking for a house right now and I
thought we could use television to get
you a house cuz you and your husband
have been looking for quite a while can
I put you on the spot can you buy me a
house
[Applause]
the answer is yes I can buy you
Wow man we've gotten away four years
every other show Ellen gives away all
kinds of amazing stuff
Oprah's flying her staff all over the
world you just put me on the spot I did
I will I will assist you I will assist
you in in buying a house I know you're
very you've been very generous to me
over the years I have let's see let's
get that out of the way yes very good
I've bought you many houses over the
years you just forget where they are now
you're more into edibles story anyway
why don't you tell America where you're
looking for a house what you're looking
for and I bet someone might see it they
might help you what's your story well my
parents are in Glassell Park in Los
Angeles
okay my husband's parents are in Sunland
so we're looking for someone because we
can't be too far from our families okay
and we're looking for a nice three into
a three into three bedroom two bath
house okay all right come on tell me
your house okay at a really cheap price
there's earthquakes so maybe wait a
minute you're now you're now sitting on
LA as a place to live
I'm just saying maybe people want to get
out of here before the big one hits and
they want to get rid of their house so
I'll buy it it's a ticking time bomb Los
Angeles is a ticking time bomb
any minute we can be in the ocean so
people should get out of here and sell
me their house
what's this took the strangest turn I
you went from being the peppy America's
Sweetheart to being this Nosferatu of
doom I really want out you want a house
well if you anybody out there knows of a
house contact the show I don't mean it I
didn't give a number real out at your TV
all right I love you so know you're a
great friend you're a great assistant
and we're gonna find our house I swear
to god we're gonna find our house sort
of obsessing everybody
[Applause]